oh
don't start
[Music]
so
okay so he goes i make contact at that
part
not out here oh no
seek contact early then the thing
then use this energy so there's harvest
energies going forward
but i twisted the top part so i twist
the top part
that's what makes him turn around that's
what makes his
other side go around me
so don't fight his arm you're over here
you're going like that
contact boom that does it
and from there secret adhesion on the
elbow boom right here
let's see if you go if you come here you
lost it you lost the technique
it's it's done this is where people try
to do this
on a guy that stopped moving
so i have to pick up a new contact point
right here
[Music]
using the elbow to keep the kazushi
pounding low
because if you power around that keeps
going
all right let's look up a second it's
very common uh uke comes in and he is
with me
eating and then we do like that
but he's he's coming
into the crosstalk side you don't do
that you do not do that
any boxer knows don't do that
so don't take advantage that the guy is
just doing one strike and you you do
this gap
you close that bridge so if you're
you're okay you're looking cool you're
looking for that
he steps into the crosstalk side you
should hit him with that
so when he comes in i'm not going like
this
i'm coming back here fading
here second correction
you cannot give him your arm he'll grab
your arm or come around like this like
well like this he's gonna grab my arm
and then he has giugi naughty
so it's your elbow is your adhesion so
i'll push your adhesion
right here that's what keeps him going
till he's here then open for the rest
up here
you cannot catch yokume you cannot
here i found it already it's here i
found it then i'm just yielding
so we're going to go to kick he cannot
catch kicks and he's
absorb
it's making just ever slow slight
contact
okay it's the same energetic kazushi
pattern so i'm going here
he had forward energy and i'm going to
take his lower half of his body this
time
so
[Music]
he goes past me
i'm going to try to make this all much
much smaller
he's going
so i'm putting myself where his foot is
going to run out of energy
is
so if you pay attention i'm not really
grabbing his leg just floating with it
just sticking with it
that's terrible
hey